okay so this is the last part of lecture
I think it's only maybe like half an
hour or something um on just
paralyzation and Transformers so kind of
like different than the stuff we've
covered before but stuff on how you
actually uh can train these Transformers
like gpt3 is like
175 billion parameters you can't fit
that on a single GPU that you need to
train on more than one GPU hundreds or
even thousands and how exactly do you do
that and this is a brief summary of the
predominant types of compute just tpus
versus gpus um I'm not going to go into
too much detail over the different
aspects but there are some things to
know about these types of Hardware in
that
um that you can kind of interpret them
similarly in terms of like flops
basically how many operations how many
floating Point operations they can do
per second the HPM size which is like
the memory size so for A1 100s it's like
80 gigs or 40 gigs for tpus it depends
could be like 16 to 32 and another
important thing which we'll kind of
allude to throughout the rest of like
this presentation is kind of the
bandwidth um mostly the the bandwidth of
the interconnect between different
devices which would be very important
because you're you're training things on
like 16 different gpus and you need to
do eventually some sort of communication
across these devices and so the
bandwidth of that is very important in
terms of determining like how big of a
model you train how much data you want
to process stuff like that which which
I'll kind of talk
about and the fundamental building
blocks of all of these at least most
like almost all these models are
basically Transformers and then
Transformers um you can basically write
write it it's just like 90% mat moles or
like 99% mat moles um and this is
exactly what these gpus and tpus can do
they can just do Large Scale Matrix
multiplications um just slightly
different different ways GPU has many
small
like computational pieces um like 8x4
by8 but like many more than tpus which
um do process differently using a
systolic array uh but in like larger
larger chunks essentially but in the end
the the end goal of these designs is
that they can process Matrix
multiplications like extremely
quickly which is also kind of why
we're I I guess it's like a a cycle like
Transformers work and really well and
our fast because a lot of they're
primarily Matrix multiplications and
they're easy to optimize which makes
people develop Hardware that does matrix
multiplications faster and faster uh and
then people do like stick more to
Transformers or like M Mo based
computation because of that because
otherwise if you do don't do that like
for stat space models there's like less
Matrix multiplications so they're
sometimes just slower purely Hardware
wise because of that even though in
theory they should be faster yeah
wait wait
sorry this I I don't know
yeah okay so now that so we know that
Matrix multiplications is basically
consisted of a bunch of mat moles right
you have your qkv projection computation
you have like your MLP with the uh
project in project out you have like
your your input dense layer your output
logic layers it's all matrix
multiplication so the fundamental
building block of sharting a model
across multiple devices let's say if we
have like a th gpus and we're training
one model how do we shart our model or
how do we divide our training so that it
can actually run on all these gpus and
also efficiently
and the the building block of this is
just m sharting so if you want to
multiply two matrices so Y is equal to X
x a all of them are matrices they can be
whatever shape let's say all squares for
now um you can do different kinds of
sharting so let's say if you do row
Shing on a and column sharting on B so
defined by the different
colors then I this is just how matrix
multiplication works is if you multiply
it out that times that is a a part of
the top
left
see so yeah so
actually we just WR from here then so
what happens if you multiply this chunk
so this this first two column the first
row of this two columns by the First
Column of the two rows then you'll get
basically a partial sum of the top left
component because the full sum is easier
I is like the full sum is is this times
this but now we're doing only let's say
half of it so this times
this and so what that means is that um
let's say if that partial sum is y1 then
Y2 would be like this thing times this
so this is like one way of charting the
matrix multiplication because in this
case you're sharting like the addition
part of of that dot
product and then what you can do is if
you multiply let's say that first half
row with all of the half columns then
you can get the like the the partial sum
of that entire
row uh you can do this for the whole
Matrix so basically if you multiply
these two halves then you'll get
basically a partial sum of like the
entire Matrix so the the full result is
the sum of these two so you're basically
breaking up this computation you're
you're breaking up this one Matrix
multiply computation into two separate
Matrix multiplications where it's the
the the green Parts is on one device
let's say and then the blue parts are
stored on device two and the question is
how can I compute this entire matrix
multiplication result and you can do the
the part
on each of the devices separately and
then after that you have to do like a
reduction across the different devices
um to sum them to actually result in
like the original y result or the one
the full output result you
want any questions about
this
okay uh and this is a different way of
sharting
so let's say if you have your full X
stored on on one device
and then you have let's say the columns
or half The Columns of a stored on like
let's say the first two columns a stored
on the first device then if you do a
matrix multiplication then what you have
is is not the partial sum is you just
have a a section of the output now right
and then let's say in device two is
there another SL oh yeah in device two
you would have you have you have like a
replicated copy of X so X is the entire
tensor X would be stored on device one
and the entire Tor X would be stored on
device two
and then device one would carry part of
would carry A1 device two would carry A2
and they each compute the the matrix
multiplication of like of its own like
part of a and then so each device would
have its own like half and then in the
end if you want to communicate the the
full result you can just do like a
gather or you can communicate each half
to each device to have the full
result so let's kind of keep in mind
that this is where like the
communication part comes in in terms of
like the bandwidth of like the faster
the communication the less overhead
because in this sense the communication
does have a cost because you have to
wait for the results to come in um if
it's super fast you don't have to wait
that long if it's really slow it may be
like a major bottleneck in your
network so this is how this is like a
lot of information um but this is how
the mat Mo
sharding Works in in like different
kinds of linear layers
so let me see if there's a do I have
another slide
here
um okay let's just talkop about this
then okay so you have you have x x here
so this is your
input and then we're can ignore this for
now so so what happens is that you you
can sh X into two
parts and then you can do your kind of
like the partial sums as we kind of
described and then this is basically
what um what was in the the first set of
slides we do where the the X and the A's
are both sharted across and then if you
want to compute the entire y you can do
an all gather so so g g here is is an
all gather or in this case what we call
an all reduce basically an all reduce is
it will uh take every device in in your
in like your network and then it would
sum up that same tensor across all the
devices so in this case you have two
devices so the all reduce would compute
y1 plus Y2 for every device and in the
end y y would be stored on every device
if you had three devices it would be Y
is equal to y1 plus Y2 Y3 or y1 plus Y2
plus Y3
um and then the part I did here is it's
F
here it's like so I guess F here is a is
a split so X is split into X1 and X2
similar to how we shown the diagram and
then the way you do your backward pass
which is kind of what what this here is
for is that in here G is just identity
backward pass and then here f is like an
all Gather in your backward pass because
one way to think about it is when you're
back propagating now you have the the
partial gradient of like dld dx1 and dld
dx2 but now you need dld DX um and it's
like basically the reverse of what our
forward process was so instead of
splitting we We Gather Instinct across
devices and then column parallel is
similar to the the second one that we
described where in this case so f is
identity in this case and X is
replicated and then now a is a split
over columns and then you can compute uh
y1 Y2 and then you can do do it all
gather um to get your full Y and the
backward pass is in a similar fashion so
since forward path was all gather now
backward path here is we're splitting
the gradients and then we back propagate
and then
um and then in that last part we
essentially have gradients from each of
the sections of a so you have to do in
all reduce over um over your devices
instead yes
um the answer is a is like a a
combination of these two I think which I
talk
about which let's see yeah it'll be the
slide after I guess this I already just
talked about so we can just skip this
okay so this is how it's done in
practice which is a little bit more
efficient basically the idea is you want
to reduce your communication as much as
possible like communication is is a is
an overhead you want to you want to like
reduce
and so the less communication operations
you do um the better it usually
is so this is an example of like the MLP
so basically you have your input X and
then you project out into like a higher
hidden Dimension and then you project
back down and the way this works is that
you can basically do replicate and then
column sharting here so this case X is
not is not sharded and then only the
your weight matrices here are sharded A1
and A2
and then and then so you compute that
mat mole you compute your activation as
usual in the MLP and then so you have y1
Y2 and then usually here in the standard
thing if you wanted y you'd have to do
an all gather but because of the way
this is constructed is that you can take
advantage of that this thing is already
sharted and then it's like the row
sharted version now because because in
the row sharted version we had to take
your take let's say x and we had to
split it into X1 X2 but here it's
already split into y1 Y2 so then we can
just feed it into like a row parallel
version and then have the sharded B1 B2
do the computation and then G there
would be an all
reduce um and then the backwards path
would be kind of similar to what I
described where uh where G would be
identity and then F there would be like
an all reduce in the backwards pass but
this is like the fundamental building
block of how like the MLP works and also
very similar which I'll show is how the
attention works as well
yes what
sorry B is the uh weight Matrix that
will map from um so let's say for for
the standard MLP a would be like uh like
it would map from Dimension D to 4D and
then B would be a matrix that maps from
4D to
D yeah any questions about this this is
probably you're going to take away one
thing should it should be this
yeah yeah uh in this case they're
already they're already pre-split like
like like you um they are permanently
stored on separate devices and they will
never be communicated collectively if
you just don't need
to so it's like on the when you
initialize it's already split yeah
yeah exactly so if you have like another
copy of it it'll just be the same uh
like an exact copy of this so it it
reduces this unnecessary communication
in the middle
basically cool anything else y
I I would say yeah like like yeah this
is like GPU one this is gpu2
yeah
yeah it it depends if if you're doing a
pie torch it's explicitly
coded yeah
if you're doing in
Jacks they can sometimes do it for you
yeah um
cool so attention is kind of the same
way it's it's basically identical
structure so you have X here it's it's
replicated and then in this case um your
qkv projection matrices are sharded and
the nice thing about this is the way
it's sharded is that it's sharded by
heads so let's say if my attention layer
has four heads and I have two devices
then each device will in the end see two
heads uh or or like store two separate
heads and then the attention computation
between heads is is like fully
independent right you can do that
separately so there's no like cross head
interaction at least in the beginning so
you can do your standard thing of doing
um
uh uh like um Computing your Q andk do
products softmax you can do drop out and
then times your times your value and
then you get y1 uh and also Y2 so these
are the results from the two different
sections of the heads and then now it's
it's like the similar thing where it's
already split in y1 Y2 so then the
output because it also attention has
also the like an output projection that
essentially mixes across heads so then
uh you can do a similar thing where you
Shard your your output dense layer into
two parts do your multiplications and
then G there is another all reduce it's
like almost identical to the MLP style
yeah
sorry sharding and parallel
oh sharding is parallel wiing like like
they're one and the
same or they are the same
yeah
yeah it's it's
parallelization I I need to compete one
big map mole I can do it into two halves
on two different machine on two
different devices so you know optimally
it'd be like two times faster
so yeah there's time speed up and then
there's also well I guess the the main
the main main purpose would be well
there is time speed up but the other
benefit would be you're shorting your
parameters so you're if you have a
really really big model then you're
dividing your parameters across
different devices so it saves memory
there yeah
um why we're not sharting qkv
or well in this case they're already
they're already sharded because the the
the projection matrices for qkv are
sharded or I'm not sure if I fully
understand question
um well they will receive different
updates I guess there's no purpose to to
to like to sharing
them
okay um so that was like a general way
of you can do charting and Transformers
and now I'll be talking about explicitly
how this charting is kind of used um in
terms of different forms of parallelism
they covering a few of them there's a
lot of different kinds but but cover
like a few main subsets the first one a
lot of you could be familiar with is
just data parallelism if you just train
anything with pytor DDP or py toor data
parallel or or any of that it's just
data parallelism um where here you can
basically treat let's say the way to
understand this diagram is um is just
some tensor and it's just the Y here is
the batch Dimension where each each row
is a separate batch element and then the
x or the horizontal is uh your your your
hidden Dimension or like your your
representation some e e dimensional
representation so it's like the shape of
this is like batched by E okay and then
the weights is let's say an e by E
Matrix and the output is like also
batched by E because we're multiplying
an e by
matrix and data parallelism is simple so
this you can treat each color let's say
green as one as device one blue as
device two and then in this case e would
be like it it's it's like replicated
across both of them so that's why it's
yellow I guess green and blue make
yellow maybe forgot um but yeah but that
but that's replicated so this is like
something that most of you have probably
done if you've trained anything on
multiple gpus um where in this case it's
like split across devices so you can see
e there is replicated and then your your
batch is split so let's say you have a
global batch size of four you have two
devices you can do a batch size of two
per device so this can save you memory
it can also save you time depending on
what your main constraint
is okay so that was Data parallelism
there's another very popular parallelism
method called fully sharded data
parallel that is fairly easy it's very
very useful and also pretty easy
relatively to understand so it's still
fully data parallel in the sense that
each device will see its own batch so
each device will see like two two
different elements let's say and then
before in data parallel you would
replicate your weights across all the
devices but now in this case let's say
what happens if we shter them across all
the devices so device one has uh half of
this Matrix and device two has the other
half and then we want to compute the
output I haven't gone exactly into how
the output is well I
guess yeah actually the way it's charted
here is that the way you compute the
output is like so for device one you do
your forward pass on the green blocks
and then now to do your multiplication
you you kind of need the full Matrix so
you do you do an all gather so you all
gather across all all your devices so
basically after the all gather every
device will see the entire e Matrix
almost as if it was replicated you think
that way which I'll kind of explain how
this is actually useful later on but
once you have the full Matrix you can
then do your standard forward pass
matrix multiplication and compu the
batch but the nice thing which kind of
stressed here is that you only need to
do this one layer at a time because in
fully in in in standard data parallelism
you replicate your entire model across
all the devices so every device at all
times stores the entire parameter
weights of your model which could be
really big 7 175 billion is like uh
seven 700 gigs or it could be like 350
gigs depending on Precision
um but the nice thing about FS fsdp I
guess that's what it's called called it
um as an acronym um is that you only
need to do it one layer at a time so
let's say uh while I'm Computing so so
let's say at layer I minus one here I am
I am I I've already all gathered my e so
I have the full e by matrix and then I
I'm doing that computation while I'm
doing the computation I can AC ously
communicate the layer after right so
this is over so there's no there's no
conflict here I the the device can do
communication and it can do computation
at the same time that's like kind of the
key thing so so basically as long as um
your com your your computation takes
long enough such that by the time it
finishes computation it reaches the next
layer hopefully it's already been all
gathered you can do the computation and
then you can move on and then once
you've done the computation you can then
split the E back up and then like keep
the The Shard of the specific device so
that's like why it saves manory it it
keeps the entire weight Matrix but only
for like a single layer at a time which
is much cheaper especially for like
really really deep
networks okay so one moderately like
mathematical aspect of this is like the
qu I kind of mentioned it's like as long
as my computation time is long enough
such that it's longer than the time it
takes to all gather for the next layer
there won't be any extra overhead so
then the question is like what is the
criteria like what what what criteria
does my model size or my training size
my training bat size need such that this
is sufficient such that um I'm doing
enough computation on a single GPU such
that the when it's done the next layer
is already all gathered and ready and
the way this is done is kind of
through some like computation of like
arithmetic int arithmetic intensity and
kind of like the bandwidth of like your
network so the way it works is the first
bullet point is we have our matrix
multiplication so this is a a batch by E
times a e by E Matrix so the flops is
two times batch by e^
squ
um and all Gathering require and and
then it's like so I have that many flops
for the matrix multiplication and then
if you want to all gather how many bytes
do I need to communicate and that's like
roughly 2 * e squ bytes if you assume
half precision
um because you just need to communicate
the entire weight Matrix
everywhere and and then arithmetic
intensity so this is a metric that's
pretty commonly used so this is
essentially the ratio of the number of
flops I'm doing the number of flops for
my computation and the amount of
communication I need to do so it's just
the the first bullet point divided by
the second bullet point so this turns
out to be equal to just uh batch per
chip flops divided by bite it's like B
like B essentially
and um and the second part or the last
part so we know the aiic intensity of
like how much how many how much how many
flops it does per bite of computation or
how much yeah how many flops it does per
per bite and the the last part to figure
out oh how how large my batch size
actually needs to be depends on just the
like the the bandwidth of like your your
device so ICI is I believe interchip
interconnect so it's the connection
between
multiple tpus or on gpus it would be the
the bandwidth between multiple gpus and
in this case the the time it takes to
transfer data between devices is um the
intensity is roughly 1,8 flops per bite
so in order to make it so that our
computation is at least our
communication is that we would need at
least batch per per chip flops or bite
so that would basically mean we would
want the batch per chip to be like
larger than 1,000
8 and at that point in in theory um
there should be no overlap or there
should be overlap
yeah as long as your batch size is
sufficiently large per device so in this
case if you wanted to train on more
devices you would be training on a
larger batch size yeah which after a
certain point is like
yeah
yeah yeah
uh in this case no they they're kind of
interchangeable
yeah um
you mean like how like an all reduce is
done or or how these collectives are
done I
guess in this case it's like
it's like kind of using the same clock
in the sense that the way these codes
will work is that let's say each device
runs the exact same sequence of of code
like exact same sequence of function
calls so they will all call all reduce
at the exact same time or or or or like
they will all they will all call all
reduce at at the same as like the M
command they run so some devices could
be behind but the the ones that are
ahead will just be blocked until all the
other ones call it yeah yeah we
doation basically
um precompute is hard it depends on
normalization so most of these
Transformers use layer Norm so in most
cases you you won't Shard over the
activation Dimension you only Shard over
batch and for that layer Norm doesn't
need any extra communication if you want
to do batch Norm you do have to
communicate like pytorch has like a sync
batch Norm that will communicate the
mean and standard deviation that and it
does add some extra
overhead okay this is um so we talked
about fsdp and this is tensor
parallelism so this is another way to
Shard this is this is exactly what I
described way before in like the the way
the sharting for the the MLP and
attention Works um
uh with to some extent yeah um but in
this case I guess one other way you can
do it so I guess there's two ways with
tensor parallelism there's there's uh
you can Shard it like like here in which
you you you don't Shard the actual batch
uh but you only Shard the the weights of
like the qkv and then like the output
projection that's one way of doing
tensor parallelism um which is like
fairly standard one other way you could
do it is that in addition to sharting
the weights you can Shard over your
activations
here which I think is in Practical
applications is a little bit less less
explicitly coded um but it still could
be used and this is very similar to the
sharding mmal stuff that I talked about
in the beginning is so now you have in
this case you can you can do like your
your part your partial multiplications
and then now you have like partial sums
and then you can uh in this case you can
you can do a reduce scatter which which
you can you can imagine as just like an
all reduce to to compute the entire
output and then you can then rehard
which is kind of like the scatter
operation so each device still only has
its own
portion uh and then you can combine
these you just get more colors so you
can do fsdp because they're not they're
not conflicting in any way you would
just need to change how you do your
devices
so the easiest way to think about this
is let's say you have 64 uh 16 devices
and then you want to figure out which
devices you want to do tensor
parallelism which devices you want to do
fsdp then what this turns out to be is
like a 2d grid so if I have like a fstp
of like four and a TP of four that would
be like 16 devices so basically each uh
if I had like a batch size of like four
then each each fsdp or each data
parallel rank would get a batch size of
one and then that would be fed through
like a sequence of um
of like four devices with tensor
parallelism across it um and in the end
you can do like some pretty complicated
computations it just gets more I guess
more annoy to
code yeah
yes no
no
uh
so in terms of choosing the sharding
that is definitely not that is manually
done right now now but it it could be
done in the future I think it's not too
hard to optimize but even coding this
parallelism like like pytorch it's like
pretty complicated like fsdp is very
complicated um especially if you want
things to to overlap when it
communicates and does computation um Jax
is a lot easier I guess since it does
that all implicitly if you use Jax um
where you don't actually because what
Jax does is it will like it will treat
the let's say you have a thousand
devices it'll treat all thousand devices
as one single device and then Jax's job
would then be to like you you can defi
you can Define certain sharting
constraints of how matrices are sharded
but it will figure out when it compiles
a graph it will figure out what
collectives do I need to do to do this
computation um versus for pytorch at
least for for now you have to explicitly
code every
communication um yeah which is not ideal
but it's also less prone to like like ja
can do stupid things where like it will
do collectives where you don't want it
to um and it can slow things down a lot
and it's hard to debug but when it does
work it's very nice um where P toward is
doing everything swissy is annoying but
it could be less a
prone but yeah to answer your question
it's like it's still it's still like a
non-trivial mod of
work yeah
um so the
the the the easiest way to think about
let's say between fsdp and TP the main
difference between these two is there're
both ways to sh your model in some sense
um the main difference is that fstp
still requires a batch size of one per
device so if I have a thousand devices I
need at least a thousand batch size
versus for TP I can have a batch size of
one across let's say four devices or
eight devices so that also lets you like
if you increase the the TP allocation
for your device is you can train on like
a lower batch size which um which may be
something you want if a single batch
doesn't fit in a single device if you're
training on like a like a one like
100,000 length sequences then that
probably can't fit in a single batch so
then you can uh parallelize it with TP
um to fit that in memory but in general
it's like as like as much fstp as
possible that's like the general rule of
them I follow
um yeah You' probably need to
use well that I'm not sure
actually is not yeah right off the top
of my head I don't know the answer to
that okay
um I
think I think I already talked about
this okay yeah cool yeah that's um
pretty much it any other questions
anything
yep oh best is to maximize
fsdp oh yeah but that's not that's not
too hard I think that's not too hard
yeah so at least with the current way
some TPS are implemented is it's um it's
like
blocking or there are some things about
memory but anyways like one aspect of it
it is blocking so so G there is an all
reduce you you can't really overlap that
with anything because it has to compute
the entire output and then it can feed
It Forward versus let's say fsdp it can
be fully
overlapped um which will in the end
result in no overhead so and and then
there's some aspects of TP which is a
little bit less memory efficient because
like here it does like a replication
which is not ideal um so it's like a
little bit less memory efficient and it
could be a little bit um it could be
sometimes a little bit slower usually I
just found that like if your bad size
are large enough then do fsdp and it
just is
better yeah
I
would well if it's a hugging face model
then um you just hope and pray someone's
done it for you
somewhere yeah that's that's hard that I
also don't work that much with them if
it's just implementing a Transformer
sharding then I I just use I just
recommend Jack or something um it's like
significantly
easier
um in
jacks or or if it's like a popular
enough model let's say llama or
something then yeah there are
implementations with charart it
there's no official implementations um
but like there is like I I I I use like
um what is it
called I forgot what it's called it was
some inference Library the the one from
from rise or or
now no um I don't know why I forgot but
anyways those support like let's say
like tensor parallelism I think is the
main one that it supports um aside from
that there isn't really anything
else aside from implement yourself which
is kind of
annoying those are mutually exclusive
you can do both of them because
attention attention sharting I explained
was over the heads and the ring
attention is over sequence length so you
can technically do both of
them cool okay I think that's all the
questions is that question okay cool
yeah
w
[Applause]